so you're sitting on your couch staring
at the Netflix menu once again frozen
with indecision life shouldn't have to
be this hard and we're here to make it
just a little easier from incredible
underrated gems to timeless favorites
that you haven't thought about in years
we've rounded up the best movies on
Netflix right now The Shining what can
you say about the shining that hasn't
been said oh 237 times before here's
Johnny even though it's almost 40 years
old Stanley Kubrick's horror tour de
force is still delivering fresh chills
and thrills to new generations part of
the reason is that homicidal psychosis
doesn't age the way Bad CG in monster
suits to Jack's slow spiral into
insanity at the Overlook Hotel ranks
just as true now as it did in 1980 not
only that but the shining is also just
damn entertaining
it's one of Kubrick's best movies one of
Jack Nicholson's best movies and one of
the best horror movies ever made my left
foot Daniel day-lewis earned his first
Academy Award for his performance in my
left foot a powerful biopic about
real-life writer Christie brown a
lifelong quadriplegic who could only
write using his toes day-lewis
masterfully portrayed all the nuances
and frustrations born of a life confined
to a wheelchair no doubt thanks to the
fact that he method acted the crap out
of the role refusing to leave the
wheelchair or break character between
takes
that's insane dedication but it paid off
my left foot is an immensely emotional
movie about one man's triumph over the
cruel hand dealt to him at Birth Hot
Fuzz Edgar Wright's 2007 hit Hot Fuzz is
arguably the best of the so-called
Cornetto trilogy which also includes
shaun of dead and the World's End the
story starts with Simon Pegg supercops
Nicholas angel a London policeman who's
so good at his job that he's making the
rest of the department look bad to save
their image
the brass reassigned him to a sleepy
little town in the English countryside
if we let you carry on running around
town you'll continue to be exceptional
and weak on ABS us of course it's only a
matter of time before he uncovers an
insidious plot hiding beneath the
perfect facade
inspired by every action movie ever and
packed with more jokes than a stand-up
special hot buzz is one of the best
action comedies ever made
hands down spotlight based on the true
story of the Boston Globe's
investigation and allegations of
widespread sexual abuse within the
Catholic Church spotlight is one of
those rare films that ignores the
sensational and dive straight into the
heart of the story with the sharp script
and brilliant cast full of scene
stealers it's no wonder spotlight took
Best Picture and Best Original
Screenplay at the 2016 Oscars like two
Pulitzer Prize winning reporting that
inspired it
spotlight is unflinching and thorough in
its take on a highly controversial
subject hush currently sitting on Rotten
Tomatoes with a 94% rating as of the
making of this video 2016 tush is an
ingenious white-knuckle horror thriller
that you can't miss the premise is
simple
Maddi a deaf-mute author is staying in
her isolated house deep in the Alabama
woods when a masked killer appears at
her window without saying a word largely
unknown actress kate siegel portrays
matty is strong capable and intelligent
a breath of fresh air for a female role
in a horror movie
Nightcrawler starring Jake Gyllenhaal
and one of his most quietly sinister
roles
Nightcrawler follows Lou bloom a
desperate young man who discovers that
he can make some quick cash filming
crime scenes and selling the footage to
the local news stations bloom gets
sucked into the seedy world and begins
an ambitious grueling climb to become
top dog in a world of bottom-feeders
with los angeles crime rates going down
I think that makes items like mine
particularly valuable like rare animals
Gyllenhaal is fantastic and first-time
director Dan Gilroy captures the grimy
underbelly of Los Angeles perfectly
evoking a sense of disquiet and barely
concealed rage that surges just beneath
the surface of both the city and its
inhabitants No Country for Old Men based
on the 2005 Cormac McCarthy novel of the
same name 2008 Oscar sweeping No Country
for Old Men takes place in the 1980s in
Texas where a blue-collar worker named
Llewellyn Moss played by Josh
stumbles across the aftermath of a
violent drug shootout in the middle of
the desert
moths helps himself to a briefcase full
of cash unwittingly putting himself in
the sights of Pavia bar dims Anton
Chigurh
a killer sent to track down the missing
money bar damn it's truly chilling as
the ruthless psychopath just one of many
standout performances in a masterful
film from cinematic visionaries Joel and
Ethan Coen The Prestige Christopher
Nolan took a short break from Batman in
2006 and released a movie about a rival
pair of stage magician struggling to
stay relevant in the late 18-hundreds if
that sounds like a total departure from
no unusual work rest assured it isn't
The Prestige almost feels like a bridge
connecting Nolan's earlier low-key films
like memento and insomnia too is later
visually stunning extravaganzas
sometimes disturbing always enthralling
and woven throughout with threads of
pure cinematic magic the prestige might
be the best movie Christopher Nolan's
ever made and that's saying a lot
chicken run is this the most original
animated animal adventure not by a
longshot but is it the best well that's
definitely open to debate held by the
team behind Wallace and Gromit and Shaun
the Sheep chicken run rebels in the same
style of goofy stop motion animation
paired with witty writing that made
those series such as featuring a rare
voice acting term by Mel Gibson's it's
one of those rare non Disney or Pixar
animated films that stands up nearly 20
years after its release as a
family-friendly classic boyhood filmed
over the course of 12 years with the
same cast boyhood tracks a child's life
as he develops from a young boy to a
college bound adult the boy Mason is
played by Ellar Coltrane who is seven
when filming started and nineteen by the
time of its release you literally watch
him age on screen as the story
progresses similarly his parents played
by Ethan Hawke and Patricia Arquette's
aged alongside them the runtime can be a
little intimidating it clocks in at just
under three hours but Richard
Linklater's groundbreaking and
heartbreaking boyhood is well worth the
investment
is offered bumpers up for kids you know
what are you 2 years old you don't want
the bumpers life doesn't give your
bumpers thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel let's check out all this cool
stuff we know you love to
[Music]